I only finished her at this moment is
reestablishing control over this
continent and every person on it
my allies are gone I'm losing you can
count on the iron back as soon as the
gold arrives
enough with the clever plan
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 trailer breakdown video today we're
going to take a closer look at the most
recent preview trailer for season 7
episode 4 so we can see what may
potentially take place in the very next
episode shall we begin the preview
starts off with another meeting between
Cersei Lannister and Tycho who is there
on behalf of the iron bank and it's no
secret that the crown has been in debt
to the iron bank for years and the
Lannisters do not have the funds to pay
off that debt which could end up
becoming a serious problem for Cersei
because typically when someone can't pay
off their loans the iron bank will then
start to support their enemies in Cersei
cannot afford to let that happen
although the Lannisters are kicking
Daenerys Targaryen zas right now they
still need to pay this debt and get the
continued support from the bank in this
clip Cersei lays out her plans of
securing the Seven Kingdoms and all of
its people under her ruling she wants to
let him know that she will have things
under control and they have nothing to
worry about because as we've seen in the
last episode Jaime Lannister sacked
Highgarden and he currently has all of
the Tyrells gold heading back to King's
Landing to pay off that debt and perhaps
even hire some more soldiers to fight
for their cause Cersei isn't just
looking to pay off the dead but she
wants an army as well and she's
currently in a very good position to get
exactly what she wants but I don't think
that gold is ever going to make it back
to King's Landing Jaime will run into a
bit of a roadblock on his way home next
we see John Daenerys
Tyrion Davos Varys and missandei on the
beach of Dragonstone Daenerys Targaryen
has now found herself in a very
desperate situation
she tells John that all of her allies
are gone Euron Greyjoy wiped out the
Ironborn fleet that she had and most of
the sand snakes were killed in Yara
Lauria and Tanner now held captive by
the Lannisters her Tyrell alliance is
now gone as well
Jaime Lannister just took Highgarden
where he had a Lenna Tyrell drink poison
and most likely died although we never
saw her die on screen we probably won't
be seeing her again for the rest of this
season the unsullied just took over an
empty Casterly Rock and had their fleet
destroyed by euron greyjoy also so now
they're going to have to march all the
way back on
les dinars can get somebody to pick them
up Daenerys does have a large force of
Dothraki soldiers still but the
Lannisters are getting stronger and
stronger by the day now is the time for
Daenerys Targaryen to take the training
wheels off and unleash her greatest
weapons which is her dragons lady Elena
told her she is a dragon and she must be
a dragon Daenerys will now take her
advice next we see Jaime and Bronn
looking over the landscape as they make
their way back from their victory at
Highgarden and I must say this is a
beautiful shot from the trailer this
kind of reminds me of Westworld a lot
during the clip of Jaime and Bronn we
can hear taiko tells Cersei that she
will have the support of the iron bank
as soon as the gold arrives Cersei is in
an amazing position right now and she
almost seems unstoppable but like I said
before I don't think that gold is ever
going to make it to King's Landing
Daenerys Targaryen is pissed and she
isn't about to allow that one-handed
bandit to get that gold all the way back
to King's Landing we then get a very
quick glimpse of someone pulling out the
Valyrian steel dagger and this is the
same dagger that was used during an
assassination attempt of bran Stark all
the way back in season one the last time
we saw this dagger it was sitting on Ned
Stark's desk in King's Landing and the
one person who knew exactly where it was
is one of the last men who actually
touched it and that is little [ __ ]
this does look like little fingers close
in this clip so it appears the dagger
has made it back to Winterfell where it
was used to try and kill someone before
and it's most likely going to be used to
kill somebody again in the last episode
we saw songs and making some
preparations for the winner she asked a
maester how long was the last winter in
the previous 100 years he said he didn't
know but he would check maester luhan's
records because he kept a copy of every
single raven scroll in this caught
little fingers attention he might be
worried there is a record and Winterfell
of his treachery and [ __ ] so when we
see this dagger get pulled this might be
a little finger looking to silence
someone in Winterfell that may have come
across some pretty damaging evidence
against him there is also a possibility
that bran may have seen something in a
flashback and he may confront
Littlefinger about it and Littlefinger
may try and silence bran
but I don't think that's as likely just
yet my first guess would be him trying
to kill the maester or perhaps even Yan
Royce or he could just be looking at it
and they want us to think it's something
more dramatic we shall see in a few days
we get another scene with the Naresuan
company
the beach and now she's really pissed
and she has done what the clever plans
and once again this rings back to what
Ilana Tyrell told her she said sometimes
you have to ignore the clever man and be
a dragon and she's ready to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
Jamie Lannister and company get back on
the road headed to King's Landing with
the wagons full of gold but one angry
dragon queen is heading right at them
with the force that's hungry for a
victory I've told you all before this
battle should be spectacular with all
the extras and horses and pyrotechnics
they use for this I'm expecting it to be
next-level for television show standards
but before Daenerys leaves she's going
to take Jon Snow down into the caves on
Dragonstone that way he can mine for the
much-needed dragonglass that he and the
realm so desperately needs I'm just
hoping to get enough to arm every man
woman and child that's going to step
foot on the battlefield
we then see Podrick bite the dust in the
next clip Podrick and Brienne will
continue to train until the time comes
for them to be needed and I'm going to
make a prediction now I think Podrick
will end up killing a major character or
he's going to end up killing a white
Walker they keep showing Brienne and
Podrick training for a reason and
Podrick isn't getting trained by no
ordinary swords woman we all know
Brianna's tough as nails
so Podrick should be getting much better
by the time that he is needed also I
think Podrick is going to get a
dragonglass weapon or he might even pick
up Brienne sword and he's going to kill
somebody I think he has to because they
keep showing us these training scenes so
he eventually has to get better and put
these fighting skills to use but let's
move on Theon arrives on the beach at
Dragonstone with a small group of
Ironborn men and this should get very
interesting because Jon Snow is there as
well and Jon might have a few choice
words for Theon we all know what
happened when feeling held Winterfell
hostage for the time that he did I'm
sure Jon's going to have something to
say about that and him not returning to
Robb as well beyond dead save sanda
though so that should be enough to keep
Jon from hurting him too bad we see Jon
Daenerys and missandei making their way
deeper into the cave and remember what
happened the last time Jon Snow was in a
cave
maybe missandei should go take a walk on
the beach and leave these two alone for
a while we also see another clip of the
training session in Winterfell and this
is most likely Brienne and Podrick
training but
Rianne could also be trending with
someone else Arya Stark will arrive in
Winterfell this episode and there is a
very good chance Arya and Brienne are
going to train together we all know Arya
loves the Train and she saw what Brienne
did to the Hound so she might want to
learn how to do the same thing with a
man of that size the dynamic between
Arya and Brienne should be pretty fun to
watch and seeing Arya and Lyanna Mormont
together should be fun as well in the
next clip
there is a scene of little [ __ ]
creeping around wonderful like always
probably making sure no one discovers
any Raven Scrolls pertaining to him but
then we get a beautiful shot of
Winterfell as someone overlooks two
castle from the hilltop and that is
already a stark a girl has made it back
to Winterfell we have seen another angle
of this before in another promo and I
always believed this was Arya start
looking at Winterfell from top of the
hill because you really can't see any
trees or anything else behind her so I
assume she was up a little bit higher
than just being on her horse this is
really cool though seeing Aria and make
it home does feel good now all we need
is Jon Snow to get here but I'm afraid
John won't reunite with them until
season 8 I think John's going to leave
Dragonstone and go straight to the wall
then after he completes his mission we
probably won't see him back in
Winterfell by the time the season ends
but I am holding out hope the songs and
bran reunion was good in the Arya and
Sansa reunions going to be good too
but it's not going to even come close to
the Aria and John reunion and the bran
and John reunion they had very loving
relationships with each other so it
should be much more impactful when John
reconnects with Arya and brand but
speaking of the Starks we see so ins a
one last time in this trailer and she's
looking over some documents or perhaps
even some Raven Scrolls that are lying
there she might have discovered
something about Littlefinger right here
in this scene and now she has to make a
decision how he should be punished
things are starting to heat up in
Winterfell now that the lone wolves are
forming a pact and I'm really looking
forward to seeing this unfold in the
north in the last scene in the trailer
is of Daenerys Targaryen flying high in
the sky on the back of her dragon and
she's on a crash course with the
lannister and Tarly army who think they
are getting away with the gold but the
dragon queen in the Dothraki will have
something to say about this Daenerys
Targaryen is flying first class
looking to send them a message written
in fire and blood
comment down below and let me know what
you think about this preview trailer was
there anything that I missed that you
want to discuss leave it down in the
comments so we can talk about it as
always thank you so much for spending
some time to watch the video I am
working on something else that I'm going
to release within the next few days and
I think it's going to blow your mind so
stay tuned for that
make sure those notification bells are
turned on because you're not going to
want to miss this but before I go I want
to give a big thanks to my patreon
supporters I really appreciate all of
you helping out this channel whenever
you can that really does mean a lot to
me I hope you all have a good day
and I'll see you in the next one bye